one of the students who helped in the
Colorado school shooting is calling the
attackers cowards and praising a friend
who died confronting one of them
hundreds gathered yesterday to honor
Kendrick Castillo he's a senior at stem
school Highlands Ranch eight other
students were wounded in Tuesday's
attack 18-year old suspect Devon
Erickson look straight down during a
court appearance yesterday the other
suspect is a 16 year old transitioning
from female to male who now goes by the
name Alek McKinney David Beck knows in
Highlands Ranch Colorado just south of
Denver with more on this story Dave a
good morning good morning Gail we're not
gonna spend much time talking about the
suspects relief at all in the story
you're about to see we're gonna focus on
the highlighting the heroic actions of
the students I want you to think for a
minute these are young people in their
own classroom in a safe space when a
gunman who is one of their own
classmates walks in and shoots at them
I'm not gonna pretend I wasn't scared
like that that stuff is immensely
terrifying Brendan Bailey says his
longtime friend Kendrick Castillo
immediately took action when one of the
shooters walked into their classroom and
pulled out the gun it happened so fast
Oh such an intense intense couple
seconds that I there was no speaking it
was just movement and fighting and
whatnot Bailey says another student
Joshua Jones joined them in the fight
the three students jumped from their
desks and slammed the gunman against the
wall the shooter fired off several shots
as they struggled with him Jones was
shot twice and is at home recovering by
Lee says he wrestled the handgun away
from the shooter but not before Castillo
was shot what he did was legendary like
he's a hero by Lee met Castillo freshman
year of high school he says the senior
was a car buff and an electronics whiz
Kendrick was a like just super kind guy
funny credibly intelligent very
memorable he wasn't just somebody who
sat in the back
Castillo's grief-stricken parents say
they are not surprised at all that their
son would put himself in harm's way in
order to save others I know that because
of what he did others are alive
and I thank God for that I love him and
he's a hero he always will be but
there's another part of you that wishes
he had just turned and ran Douglas
County Sheriff Tony Spurlock is not
releasing a lot of details but he did
confirm to CBS News that the shooters
entered the campus through the middle
school entrance where there are no metal
detectors the sheriff told us the
suspects were armed with handguns that
they were not old enough to legally own
there's a report out there that a guitar
case was used to conceal a weapon is
that correct yeah I'm not gonna confirm
that at this point because we're still
in the process of that scene they did
get those guns into the school through
arusian and we're still investigating
that this coward who came into our
school attempting to wreak havoc and
hurt people he lost like he completely
and utterly lost Brendan says the male
suspect was really acting strangely most
of the day leading right up to the
shooting there was a memorial last night
to honor the students and a lot of the
people who showed up were chanting
mental health mental health John the
young man who died was going to graduate
from high school tomorrow David thank
you for bringing us Kendrick Castillo
story the hero thank you